you have a hundred percent of my trust
until you don't same I don't think
enough of us are looking at the world
that way right now we agree your
distrust and major disbelief and you
come in with me bro until you earn it
what the are you why are you so
audacious who the made you
special enough that another human has to
earn it where's your humility I say yes
I give trust at first you can lose it
people like trust is earned I'm like
cool that seems slow and egotistical
like who the am I to have it earned
to me trust is given and then you lose
it if you're a dick face incapable and
have proven that you're not worthy of
the challenge or the role